[Music]
welcome to winners on a Wednesday this
week we have four winners on a Wednesday
these guys have formed a fantastic
collaboration came on the crash course
last year well you came on the crash
course last year give some incredible
things financially free living in well
actually living in Poland living in
Poland just guys why don't you just tell
us what on earth you guys are like
maniac to see you on Facebook doing
deals all the time or when we met at the
crash course you had a massive fire in
your belly you told me I'm gonna be on
winners on Wednesday next year actually
I'm gonna be financially free it would
have been easy not to believe you
because you were living in Poland you
had no money and you've done some
incredible things so what did you just
kick off and tell us what you've been
doing over the last four months so over
the last 12 months when I started at the
crash course in February Manchester I
got more orientated educated myself on
property etc by then at the crash course
I signed up for the Diaz DfE as well
which I joined in May 2018 here in
Wolverhampton lovely weather we had good
education lot of information this was
the basis for my property knowledge and
yeah without that I wouldn't have been
so far as well now I started do sourcing
I formed my sourcing company to acquire
sourcing Ltd by then it was Ltd nowadays
for a property Solutions Ltd I just
changed the name a fully compliant
company and from summer 2018 to the end
of the year I sold over 20 deals on all
of them but you came on the crash course
in February yes
and since then you've sold over 20 pop
to do yes I made about how much money
from that well it's a bit hard to say
because since I was starting company I
didn't charge an exact amount so what
one views I really had to sell them
because I needed the money so you
stopped exciting deals quite low quite
low yes and then you started building up
so what's the range there
what with the lowest and the highest the
lowest is 400 pounds okay and that is
the queen of 20,000 so that so you
certainly saw 20 deals the lowest was
forward to pound an average would be
around about what let's say I think 16
1669 Ricky okay that's that's fantastic
yes Christ just fantastic okay and how
did you call guys all right
yes myself in Giovanni but as we come
from Cambridge and with my personal
myself just left six for some time 20
this year to party 22 this year we came
together purely because of the
inspiration entrepreneurship financial
freedom both working a punting job in
Cambridge the famous river punts in
Cambridge home full of teenagers coming
out of school and it brought us together
and that essence talking about business
and from then on we came to a crash
course in August we met Alistair
Cunningham in the crowd and he was
really the pinnacle of our decision to
go further property you know taking us
aside and actually we stayed up to three
o'clock in the morning in the Hilton
talking talking about how we can take
the next steps for you but without it's
there you make a mistake
oh wow amazing um really inspirational
and we we put a lot of value in that
someone we don't know we just met that
day and its really showing us the
possibilities of poverty and that I mind
with my future yeah and from then on we
think go to the course that you have DfE
you mean you did the crash course but
you didn't do the advanced training
right that's right yeah
so we thought that we could be
resourceful just us two and three
networking and hard work we've found
journal Facebook which is a very
powerful tool for us actually on your
property investors yeah whichever will
eat right that's how we found each other
so so I'm trying to work out how you
guys will put together exactly so you
you came on the crash course in yeah and
you were just like oh he's probably
selling deals yes you guys came on March
yes you're coming next mark well the
next this month coming yes so how did
she go to collaborate because she sounds
like you've all done reasonably well and
you've got other you've got a great
background story yes
actually I'm important to you for two
years now I'm just I find the guys in
team in face because well and I just
miss working to the face within your
Facebook it's really good because I
didn't know any of the teams and we just
start doing each other from the Facebook
which is really good and yeah just
trying to know each other and start
doing the JV with each other more yeah
more and more and more as a team I
believe a redoing really well because
all of the guys is separate there we are
doing really well yeah let me ask you a
question and you've been the property a
couple years I know at the moment you
you're doing some really good when to
rent deals and all stuff what you're
doing is a group why do you think you
you'll go further or get more money or
it maybe it's not about the moment as a
group they're just all working
individually yes this is actually great
question and as a team each it can earn
more they've been be our unity yeah we
each of us got it just expertise in area
for example boys are really good in
finding area finding the deal and gun is
really good to finishing the deer I'm
speaking to that okay speaking to the
landlord on finishing the deer yes when
we doing sex accommodation is in at the
moment and for the just decoration and
just the finishing touch are just
helping guys to do the property just a
bit outstanding yes and we do all the
process and each of us doing the area
that we are just expertise on so
basically what you're saying is you've
got skills
you guys have got skills did you guys
know each other already yeah I came
across your book yes
we then presented it to Malou red you're
booking up a bails the way you wrote it
you know bra love you know the energy
that you you brought into the book it
was very inspiring and we put onto your
course strapped to that and me and maloo
went to give up and then after that
start networking on Facebook met Jen and
how it brought us to Manchester so
you're from Poland Joan
well actually I'm Dutch born yes but I'm
living in Poland okay okay so you're
you're you're living in Poland you're
from Holland
you guys are uk-based born and better
than UK I get feeling you're not yeah
but we've got beautiful accent so it's a
really interesting team that you've got
set up so what what I'd love to do is
I'd love to hear about what you've
achieved as a team as a partner yes the
deals that you doing how much money
you're making and then I'd love to talk
about some of the pros and cons to
partnership maybe some of the challenges
to that Gibson give someone who loves
are watching this you might be thinking
sugar on my own you know there is a team
every can brainstorm the pros and cons
are back draw some lessons to how's that
sound so what why don't you tell me I
mean Jen what what for you how many
deals that you figured of 20 girls yes
that as a group is that you well
actually those 20 deals are as a
sorcerer so yeah me a separate will be
part of the group that was before the
group yet before the team but to when we
decided actually Jim honey you and I
next end of December 2018 beginning of
January
okay we're not going to sell on the
deals if they are good deals we take
them on ourselves so basically before
forming this partnership yes your
strategy because you can have any money
I know in fact your backstories is kind
of incredible because I remember having
dinner with you at the deal finding
extravaganza yes
just just give a few if you don't mind a
little bit of backstory about about your
life and about why you got into property
because it's quite it's quite incredible
yeah well a bit of my backstory
I am an entrepreneur 19 years now when I
was 21 I just went to the Dutch chamber
of commerce and say I want to register
my own company yeah what kind of company
I don't know just my own company and
then I decided to set up a def Bailey a
debt collection company because you
didn't need to have any licensing for
that etc 2001 financial crisis so should
be a bit of money to be made as a debt
collector yes and that's how I started
then I met someone who taught me about
company formations etc and I switched
from a debt collector to company
information agent I've done that
business for seven years after that I
went into seals of terror fans they
wanted to put a tour in caravans yes for
behind your car from that I went into
static mobile homes a bit bigger ones
but I'm camping places etc and from that
I went into the construction of timber
frame ecological houses yeah I had a
construction I still have the
construction company but there's a lot
of competition in Poland and actually
the whole process of setting up this
cross friction company brought me into a
lot of deaths yes and that was why so
five out of money so you have a business
in Poland it didn't go too well in
German when he came to England
you were skint yes likes kids kids get
in absolutely and you're at the crash
course you had absolutely no money but
how did you afford to do the advanced
training at the deal fine extravaganza
borrowed money you borrowed money yes I
borrowed money that it is yes I'm really
glad I did because as I said the correct
course in the DAV were the basis of all
my property knowledge and it still is
from there I go yeah everything that I
decide no one can take back knowledge
Dex correct no wasn't ever tacit
knowledge and the thing is it's really
interesting German because I remember
sometimes people come to
the crash course and they say I'm
absolutely scared I've got no money I
wanna borrow money to do the advanced
training what do you think Samuel and
I'm like I can't advise you know I can't
advise because if I it depends on the
person for some people it would be a bad
move because yes if they're absolutely
scared they've got no money to borrow
money to go into debt to do a program
that they might not implement anywhere
it could be a bad move however it could
be a really good move in your instance
it was audited I'm just like do what you
need to do man I'm not going to
encourage anyone to get to death but but
the thing is I'm not going to tell
anybody not to because if I said I don't
borrow the money and get into debt to go
on the advanced training then all would
be robbing people like you of the
success that you've now done so I just
think everyone has to make up their own
mind but but look at the results man
yeah so as a result of the deal farming
extravaganza which is which is a very
good program yes you went on to sell 20
property deals making a round about on
average selling them to 15 in Japan yeah
so I'm making maybe about 30 brownies
and you know what and in Poland I'm sure
it's a it looks like a lot more than
that yes well that's actually the thing
it looks like a lot more it is a lot
more because it's times four point seven
eight something at the moment so in
Poland knocking backing like you can
live on that money for like three years
maybe yes if you don't have a
construction company so so so you were
doing deal selling to get yourself out
of debt yes it get yourself a bit of
cash yes you were learning because the
great thing about deal sourcing is when
you find deals and sell them on you're
actually learning about Pompey yourself
as well yes so as long as you're selling
good deals I mean how the investors
getting on now that bought from you well
some of them well a lot of them they
were in property already yeah one of my
clients is in property for 17 years yeah
and he said your numbers do stack up
there okay your calculations are right
all the information that you provide
provide actually I don't need any more
details you did all the due diligence on
the property yeah so we are they are
doing well because they were already but
also new
investors that bought for me they're
doing well if they are not doing well I
don't know because a lot of people don't
shell when they are not doing well so
yeah I mean if the bottom line is you
were trained well you learned how to
find good deals you learned how to
package them you look up so they should
be doing well I think sometimes set them
to existing investors is the best yes
because it's like all of these already
existing investor if you said to me
something I found a deal and these are
the figures I'm going to look at it
based on the figures it is a good deal
it stacks up it's gonna save me time
Oh 2,000 pounds which is gonna save me
time and I value my time so I totally
get that
I get how you saw 20,000 sorry 20 20 no
20022 deals which is which isn't
incredible they must be another question
how did you cuz i how did you find and
sell 20 property deals in the space of
what like six twelve months yes well not
twelve months let's say nine months nine
animation of nine months living in
Poland how did you end up well I did it
all remote the only thing I needed is a
laptop a phone and an internet
connection
yes a good internet connection will be
fine to go to all the websites to find
the properties calculate the utilities
etc the council Texas and I opened
Facebook when I was working on my plane
before the DAV so I think I opened my
facebook account the 23rd of May 2000 so
you had a brand new Facebook accounts
brand new brand mix especially open for
the DAV yes and oh yeah so other did the
bill probably extravaganza you said you
made a lot of contacts
yes yes I made a lot of contacts did you
sell to some of them no no one of the
[ __ ] absolute commission but yeah I'm
doing your commercial now Oh
not quite but okay so let me ask you a
question then remotely how did that look
like and what were the smaller than
processes are farming property selling
it remotely so what I've done
after the deer view the DAV also Ellis
there told me about how to get fully
compliant etc I sorted that out and yeah
I just want our Facebook and loads of
property groups contact with people
posting posts that people will come to
me of course
tripwire sourcing has a Facebook page as
well yeah people came over their
mailings through milking
well it's milking the Rileys people can
use other system but mailings and yeah
that's how people came to me yeah and to
them I saw the deal all my clients to
whom I saw the news I found them on
Facebook for only freshmen fantastic and
the properties did you did you how did
you find the properties is going on
websites like open rental right move
search them on the country country yeah
yeah yeah and you just contact the
landlords yeah negotiate deal
does anyone view the properties before
you say how does that work well I had
people as well just my contacts close to
the area I asked them to visit it and so
they do a report that pictures you know
to sell the deal and then on the basis
that I mean the eventually goes checks
it out check it out check sees happen if
he is but I also had five or six sources
that were not compliant so their Shores
their own views they send their numbers
to me I ran them through my calculator
yeah and when I say yes okay for me it
stacks up we can sell this one we split
it so finally that's was sort of the
before word Japan because they were yes
amazing okay so so you're doing this you
do really well deal sourcing you guys
before the partnership was formed then
what what sort of success what you
haven't
Malou is a sick form student yeah time
that we met I was kind of like trading
Forex
and looking to you know something other
than university some that's going over
rock yeah
then began reading on property read
Robert Kiyosaki's book yeah from there
when into your book it's always the
white people we've Robert Kiyosaki's
book then then read my book and then
come to the crash course that then end
upon winners Wednesday yeah and there we
went on the course I think we were the
youngest minimally were the youngest
there come on how are you um I was 21
when I went you that's not that young he
was everything when he started yeah all
seven saying that but yeah still
relatively young right yeah yeah and the
obstacle was to you know get money from
you your dual sourcing extravaganza
which we didn't have at the time yeah
she was the students so we decided to go
through the implementation right yeah
every day sometimes people thick the
crash course all the crash course is
just like a and taste their preview the
crash course is on steroids right it all
depends how you interpreted it yourself
what you do with the information yeah
the crash course provides a lot of
information and I know of members of
your Facebook group there are a lot of
people that were successful without well
there have been videos of winners on
Wednesday yeah of guys girls as well
they didn't go to the DMV and they were
successful because of just the crash
course yeah of course it is so so so so
you guys have gone to the crash course
so what what what what if you had any
success prop in property before the
partnership that's the thing because we
don't know how to start we're gonna no
money at all we're thinking of getting
loans I should go into your DVD course
as well yeah and so what value did you
bring to the table then how did you
because you've got you've got Joe he's
done 20 deals make thirty thousand
pounds
starting off then and then I'll get to
you in a moment what what why did what
value did you bring assumption we needed
to get more
yoanne was a beautiful set and we had no
background in good sourcing yeah so we
went on YouTube and connected with both
other dual sources okay so it sounds to
me like you know you guys were hungry
you have some knowledge because you've
been on the crash course yeah
yeah you've got a fire you ready to
implement which is fantastic
um what why why did what what what did
you party with them
well what I saw in them is a lot of
motivation and when they asked me a
question they picked up very quickly
yeah the questions that I provided that
support that's very important I want to
go forward issue FC from February on and
yeah and I don't want to stand complain
look back yeah I look back just to learn
for me to learn from my mistake
yeah mistakes and go forward and that's
what I've seen with these guys as well
yes and the communication was very
smooth that's motivation good
communicators let's give another
question then I was gonna question one
things were and the question is answered
and a project was easy for me when the
connection is good the relationship is
linear in UK so you're thinking these
two guys then they're not there what
brilliant portfolios have had much
success in property but they've been on
the crash course yes they're intelligent
yeah hungry they're multi abs they live
in the UK and you thought that could be
really valuable yeah absolutely within
that yeah so we we we after the crash
course we were following up with people
that we network with and they said rents
the way to go and we decided that when
we go back to our hometown we're gonna
learn as much as we can we ended up
finding networking events such as pin
promised to invest he had worked my
summer gypsy actually on our second
occasion we met some urgency as well so
that was really nice and good timing for
us it was the summer of 2018 and we
decided that we would go straight to the
pin hosts Christina she said I'll be a
guarantor if you finally get doing
aspects up and that give us a lot of
faith to go out and actually find deals
in our town and we started to go antic
laying agents and stuff like that but
sue and make a website quickly and Wix
try look as professional as we can in a
city where affluent Cambridge University
towers we find it quite a barrier to
gets that kind of respect in the
property industry as young as young guys
and then of course through
resourcefulness we found on YouTube deal
sourcing a education decided that a
chemical dual source and stretch all
over the UK yeah and from that we
stopped fighting H bike deals in areas
such as though Newcastle and there was
such as Birmingham in Manchester yeah
finally ghost doing the numbers up doing
our due diligence and eventually got to
a pinnacle where we can really sell the
deal was on fund investors maybe they
were trusting our figures enough and so
on and so on so we decided to reach out
on Facebook we see beautiful community
communities on Facebook people have make
each other and conversation starts as
well and we decided to make a personal
Facebook on the group who sold who sold
15 days before we need your help we
would like to network and tell you a
story you tell us yours which is a great
post because you know and I think you
guys all watch it because I watch you on
facebook and I watch what you do and
it's incredible really because a lot of
people they just spam groups you know
I've got a deal but buy my stuff for my
deals and all the happens easily they
that just repels people that the admins
bought them from the group because it's
like you know you just spamming the
group's but what you guys do so well if
you add value and you know so hey we'd
like to give some tips so is there
anyone here that's do deals and you just
you know network really well-versed and
off the back of it you make a lot of
money lucky tricks like and we thought
that it was almost natural though Joe
came into our experience were just the
inspiration just to come on the group
and say look we may not be as an
experience but we're open to learn we've
got the hang of the fight and we're
looking to stretch our arms and legs and
and learn from people that have more
experience and it came at the right time
for Joan as well as we we let this cover
and the punishment ever since then has
been a bit of what a for success
when did the partnership stop
yeah we were in three months yeah
November I think we're gonna contact and
yeah we had our chance at set where we
discuss nothing be great to hear in a
moment about what I know you got to do
great things
yes since the partnership was formed
just two or three months ago which we
can get to in a minute
kind of got your back story which is
hungry motivated intelligent based in
the UK you gern just absolute beast
Psalm 20 deals from Poland remotely I'd
love to hear a little bit about about
your backstory prior to to the
partnership so what's your thoughts on
now in property okay
I'm working with my husband oh yeah I'll
be doing that for a living but uh I've
done karate resourcing and because we
had we have all business we come with
some of the problems some of the stuff
left and I had to work long for about 40
Danny be down to a day off and it was to
mess at the time yeah I've just a we had
a headache
and I've just forgot everything about
purpose yet at that time after seven
years I've been to the course and I
supposed to do HMOs yeah but I am in
mentorship on that courses there but yet
networking I found Dan in the Facebook
networking and he just offered to do a
service accommodation and I just said
yes I mean I'm happy to do a service
accommodation yeah i we just start doing
these things we together we didn't know
each other much but the Facebook was
really good yeah
- just decided James taught a lot the
mastermind behind all of this yeah he's
kinda the one that kind of makes you
invites people to this partnership which
is gonna take over the world right okay
so DC okay yeah we're taking over the UK
okay again so so what what value what's
your role then within this partnership
actually if you start I was it started
as a JV cash partner yeah I put the cash
in videos but I've just got this idea if
someone gave me opportunity mmm I will
take it at the time I don't know how I
will I will just make it at the end but
I will say at the time and then work out
how I would yeah cuz you don't even
you've not even been on the crash course
yeah no but absent most of your inactive
you know it's different
most of the videos that you pull on the
face you German I'm subscribed and I've
seen every single one hi Polly
how much how much can we decide how much
better is the cross goals than the
videos well before he learned in life
you know yeah for me to crash course
we've the high five yeah yeah actually
doing them only that's such a
motivational Drive yeah it plus all
deformation videos are great videos you
get the phone you get a lot of content
but then the crash course you do it
anything happens you before I'm gonna
start that course and I mean Dementors
yeah so you know what you know what if
you just get one did you just hit one
day oh yeah always look back but let me
ask you a question so you're coming on
the cross course next month
yes so you put some so basically you
worked on a lot the investor so you've
bought a bit of money into the because
you've seen you've seen urine
you've seen how good is passionate
you've seen these boys I'm smart they
are and you've thought this is going to
be really successful
the one thing that none of you have got
I mean you some deals and stuff but it's
it's a complete zero start of ripeness
yeah well actually what debt
we met with Oksana as we came up with
the idea okay we haven't you know we
took on we had a lot of viewers also a
lot of potential news but later around
the length or changed mind etcetera so
basically we started with previous
contract signs etc and we wanted to
recycle our money the money that we
invested in it so how can we do that the
numbers are good a minimum profit of 700
pounds net profit per calendar month
yeah so and most of the deal did cost us
around three and a half K to set it up
yeah by all the small stuff like cutlery
etc microwaves so we said okay Queen of
K even if we do a very good
JD program they join up with us for
three and a half K we get our money back
because we always negotiated a part of
the first month rent free deposit free
since we work with rent guaranteed
insurance etc oh that insurance also
covers damages from our side to the
property up to 50,000 pounds yes which
is way better than just the positive
want to pay something like that and we
said okay so the investor invest three
and a half K whose the investor well
okay yeah I won't call it any investor I
will call it a JV partner yes because we
JP etc yes and the first JV partner what
is f sana and we are together now into
into deals it's a good question the
business the business that you set up
for sickles tripwire property solutions
this is stands for amazing a portable
apartment amazing affordable apartments
so we're gonna talk a little bit about
the business you know what you've done
in that's couple dogs from the business
because I thought and prior to that
you've done a little bit of poverty
worked out okay maybe solicitors not
okay really busy with your business
you've got somebody you wanna invest it
and rather than investing a little bit
of money into property you've seen the
opportunity if you can invest that money
into a property business and be a
partner you think you're gonna have got
a lot more money right and that hang off
yes yes I thought good you guys got it
yeah
you're like mastermind so I kind of
understand it because I must say this is
the probably the craziest winners
Wednesday we've ever does a high five
for that man wrote to the car park and
and I saw you guys all studying
collectively outside taking selfies and
I was just thinking this is gonna be fun
you know but I kind of have got my head
run I understand now the partnership and
what you've done
are you gonna are you able to do your
own deals outside of the partnership in
due course or is the partnership like
the every sin would be off put robots to
go through this like what's the plan
well did you the agreement it's not set
up like that it's not a binding
relationship yes and with us actually we
don't have agreement right in between us
and we can't wait to get a works out and
everyone off a lot of course is allowed
to take on his own deals okay so so you
know you work up to the deals know so
the deals that you do together you do
want to deal my deal base is where
status this deal would work really well
for us flexibly should we put it in the
group should we never to joint venture
yes we will
in which case on this deal will work out
50/50 or whatever it might be
yeah great stuff you can also do your
own deals so so you've got your own
businesses but then you also do this
together that makes it I think that's a
smart like to do it sometimes people say
you know we're gonna set up a business
and all of the deals have to go through
this business and if you're going to do
that you have to be you have to get
proper contracts its list too involved
but the way you're doing it deal by do
basis I think that probably makes sense
you're tied up on the agreement and it
doesn't give you any space yes it to go
to the left or to the right up to four
or it that's a really good tip that's so
if you want a joint venture with
somebody rather than thinking we have to
joint venture a whole line no and no do
it on a deal my deal basis yeah so this
deal would be great because I can put
this in you can put this in hey let's do
it together
yeah great it's brilliant this deal you
can have that and I'll have this I think
that I think that makes it
yeah that makes sense for me it makes
sense as I said otherwise you would be
tied up and when the JV doesn't work out
then your whole business system yeah
Emami the increased pom you think this
business that we've all got together I
think I'm adding more value even it
creates problems if you're gonna deal
what Bo Bice's I think this deal doesn't
work out you only have to solve your
problems with debt particularly JV
partner yeah and the other abuse will go
on plus they will provide you with your
income this this deal doesn't provide
you with income yes maybe but those
views are and how how many deals they
have you done together since she started
a couple of months ago with option and
we are into dues now yeah and we are in
those three that we have with another
tree coming up and we need to close on
down this week yeah and those three
Dale's people so so far that's a couple
of months you have three deals between
you is that right yes
and what pointed nails at what one of
those of those service combination oh
and that's right to service from grapes
yes yes okay and what kind of monthly
cash flow are you getting or expecting
to get from those we always calculate
them conservative minimum 700 pound net
profit per calendar month yes
and they should do between 7 1 K yeah
depending on the location very dependent
on the management company that you
choose me really important yeah yeah how
they manage their property yeah I know
you have some challenges with some bad
management companies though yes some
things that they didn't say they were
going to do and vice versa but that's
learning right that's a you know dr.
Mitch learning and yeah it is an issue
but we will definitely get over it yeah
Joan are you fine actually free would
you so what I have a look at the income
yes yeah I have to sort out other
financial issues that I have from these
businesses yes for my previous so how
much money would you stand now for from
from doing the crash course and the DFA
last year yeah
in career-making from property today we
decide each month between 700 and 1,000
but which which for me is enough yeah to
run my business with and leave the
opponent with my family
what why do you what why do you look
upon so much because you were born in
Holland hold on you're born in Holland
you invest in the UK but you live in
Poland why Holland it's right about
another comment yeah the triangle I
would make it the other way around I'm
coronated born in Holland went to Poland
because of the moment race yeah we
bought a lot of second-hand mobile homes
we transported them to Poland renovated
them holes I mean Poland and formal
eastern Germany I love the country I
love the mentality yes I love my wife of
course Bobby's idea and yeah that's the
main reason that I said so first it was
business then I met my wife and I said
okay this is my that's a home country
yeah where to live but then because the
business was going worse financially
speaking either I started to worry in
tithing what to do and I can't came to
property yes then I was thinking because
it was started for me the first video on
property was from an American guy that
was doing house clippings ok but America
is a bit before yes
so I was thinking which country is the
best I know the Dutch property market
for a long time I was 16 when I first
got interested in debt yeah and it's
pretty ok but a lot of tight regulations
for landlords etc I mean he did a lot of
research about where the best place yeah
my my and why did you come to the
conclusion that England was the best
place to make money in property in
England you have a lot of strategies
HMOs rental rent delays complications
it's something that most of the people
didn't hear about a polar yes we sold
our apartment on a delayed completion
and people are like what what did you do
is that legal yeah yeah yeah and yes in
the UK it's only a lot of possibilities
renting is very popular in the UK as
well it's in Poland everybody biases is
how they do rent but for extremely high
prices yes oh yeah for me
plus the relation the British Pound
Sterling to the Polish zloty yeah give
me the best in return so how's my change
for you guys then since you started out
now in property for myself being a
unique up to me in German coming
financially free decided to to leave uni
and pursue this all time because it's a
full time now because we're an income
from properties and as a student I don't
need how much can we make enough for
properties similar to Jones or 700 so
700 to 1,000 pounds that's none of your
my again
yeah that's each so kind of because for
now at this moment obscenities in the JV
view okay so she gets a 50% of the net
profit anyway yeah with a minimum of 350
that that's the deal we set up and we
shall split between each other oh so
she's getting a little bit more she
might be problems you know then I mean
the half they are financially free yeah
is it wrong it's gonna be yeah captain
again another thousand yeah so about two
thousand pound a month yeah yeah yeah
because you that's at the moment yeah I
mean media half being financially free
because what's the what's your target to
be financially three or four thousand a
month yeah yeah yeah four thousand a
month is it is a comfortable an hour
right yes yeah but if you're making two
thousand pound of uncle wedding you've
only been in this business two months
it's not bad how much money did you
invest into the business seven thousand
that's know a lot
pretty nice generally okay believe that
so this January you had no properties
because it's 7,000 you've now got three
properties you're making 2,000 pound a
month approximately seventy two thousand
seven hundred twelve thousand seven
hundred to a thousand and you just can't
get it started
that's a massive achievement dead agent
but you must be pretty pleased and
excited yeah yeah exercise to come we
set the intention before the start the
year that a million pound portfolio 50k
income by the end of the year ye summer
says a bit too much but I think the
momentum that we've got now and the way
we're Jenny to go as a team as has been
great and you know more deals to come
what is your family thank ya very proud
a consumer background will come from
background so my mother said I flew my
father's British and yeah
just I said top upbringing pinnacle in
my teenage years realizing the power of
your mind and essentially just putting
that to practice and attracting a
prosperity since then and now yeah
yes we're inspiring there because the
fact that you've come from not unit I
mean you weren't bought one of several
spoon in your mouth no I would say so no
you come from a tough background you
know what sort of what do you what are
you parents do full of them well that's
the thing like there's not really nicer
to the question I went through a stage
ago for foster care stuff like that and
family not being around too much I say
I'm gonna go too much into it
but yeah a lot of emotional trauma stuff
had that things to heal personally I'd
say I'm in a much better place than I am
now
god bless to my friends and family that
have been there and the right times of
stuff like that I've made a lot of my
friends in my lifetime family and that's
one of the things that I'm carrying with
me now I'd say Giovanni has been one of
them and yeah just in that essence being
curious about how to heal yourself in
that sense and projecting a beautiful
future vision for yourself I'm making
that reality I think I think that's
where everyone to do we all have such an
amazing tool for our disposal or I say
this boys about a tool that we have
to attract the things that we want in
life - yeah yeah and I think I think if
you couldn't take away one thing is not
be afraid to ask because I think a lot
of the opportunities that I've come to
us now have been from not being afraid
to ask you know the doors I've been open
for us because we've been able to ask
them this one of the things you have to
push aside in yourself and just
surrender to the fact that there are
people out there to help and I think
definitely the Facebook group has been a
perfect reflection of that finding and
just trusting in the process that we can
come together in the UK no matter where
we come from yeah only a couple hours
drive from the airport and here we are
together at Manchester and ever since
then
Manchester's been our home and we'll
continue to take more deals continue to
network and find new friends and it's
been a beautiful journey so far we we
can't wait for the end of the year and
see how far we've come
this is a cool night that's so cool what
would you say to somebody that was
watching this who maybe had a similar
background to yourself and just because
a lot of you know a lot of people I
speak to people and they say they think
just because they haven't got a lot of
money or you know they haven't got
family here in property that they can't
they can't do it someone who comes from
a sinner that country self that's
thinking they're taking themselves out
the gang because they're thinking my
backgrounds mean bad I've got a rough
upbringing I've not got any money I
can't even afford the training but what
would you say to them because you were
in that situation and now you've
achieved so much and you only just
getting started so what would you say I
mean it's just it's just the awareness
of just looking around and seeing how
much there is
how much rich there is and just being
curious and seeing yourself being a part
of what's going on and I probably said
too much I haven't got any quotes or
anything over top of my head no what
would be your biggest piece of advice to
someone who's say yourself two years ago
or six months ago you potentially what
would be your biggest piece of advice
from your experiences
I think everyone has that potential
inside of them
there is accuracy one more for yourself
yeah and what's your what's you what
what do you want these up what's your
strongest reason why why are you doing
this I think on the baseline is to prove
a point and it's to look back in and say
that what's happened in the past doesn't
define me and hopefully the future we
can all teach others the power of their
mind and and what powerful thing it can
can do for people and yourself any
family as well I hopefully this could be
a motivation for others this reaches up
to friends and family of homers as well
as that was what do you want what are
your friends and family think of what
you're doing that's the thing like to be
able to go on a path like this you have
to kind of step away from the noise and
and really kind of look within yourself
and kind of entrepreneurship as a whole
is it's kind of like a solo journey I
think yeah craving that life for
yourself with opportunities that we have
you you tend to get back the friends and
the firma stuff like that because you
realize that actually in a few years
time you put the work in and you can
come back and show them what was where's
the potential reason you want to really
inspire your the people from your
background your friends and family you
wanna show them what's possible yeah
definitely yeah that's cool well it's
you know what I mean this goes for all
of you but if you need any help or
support you get stuck on a dealer or
yeah you know what you know where we are
absolutely you know it's drop drop me a
message drop us a message yep because
you beautiful people and I'm so proud of
you guys I'm so proud of you guys thank
you I mean what you've achieved is
remarkable and I think you're all coming
from a really good place as well you
must be really really proud you know
we're really grateful to meet her
yeah thank you so much yeah cool what
the plumbs then what's the next what's
the next big deal well we are now on a
few news as I said two or three three
properties that we're going so you're a
you're about to get three more that
might give me the
really the wheel yes financial freedom
and then there's comfortable financial
freedom not and the next step will be
for us as we already mentioned our goal
is to get a portfolio at the end of the
year of 1 million yes a wharf plus a net
turn over nearly turn over 50k yeah is
that each other as a business a business
50 Cal silic a turnover yeah well
terrible problem
it's already perfect yeah yeah yeah yeah
otherwise it was not much sorry for that
so that's our goal
once you're getting pretty much there or
wedding now 50k I mean profit a 50 count
ovary yeah yes yeah yeah but for me it's
more like the rental rent I still have
the feeling I don't own the box if you
want to make sorry you want to make 50k
closet from your own portfolio yes from
your own portfolio so the key now is you
do move to right do sourcing controlling
properties you make a decent cash flow
yes which enables a useful time property
what's your strongest reason why really
like I'm not UK born
wait born born in Portugal okay you guys
are right international but yes only one
that's a ball in the UK right yeah yeah
yeah okay so um born in Portugal went
through some family traumas as well
can I was younger some close close
family passed away and we're to move
away from Portuguese living went through
primary schools different primary
schools losing c2c ended up living in
Cambridge and that's where I found Aaron
and Emily in there from there she's been
trying to make the most of the situation
down Charmian and yeah
poppy has been the perfect vehicle for
that I mean full-time full-time I
promise he's a good achievement yeah
because no matter you're not what 22 now
yes not many 22 year olds because I I'm
a full-time property onto the
how's that bill feels amazing would you
say that properties came to life
oh yeah most definitely and as you said
is just the start yeah so come with the
end and see what between-group yeah what
are your individual what are your
individuals I know you do properties as
a group you're also gonna be do things
individually what's your kind of
personal goals for me is to build as big
as possible 15 service accommodations
really interested in the developments as
well yeah but what's the personal reason
behind that says let's say you've got 15
serviced accommodation properties you've
got development projects let's say you
own a castle whatever what what are you
then gonna do with your time on with
your money what's the real reason
because I can tell you a passionate guy
Oh
travelling yeah which is possible other
you know experiences here and there
doing traveling but no they're having
that income coming in every month it's
gonna allow them to do that even more
yeah
very sports professional I'm not but the
entrepreneurship side if he was not
allowed me to carry their own so thank
you go back to that and what did you
study at unit economics so you studied
economics at uni what were you planning
when you first signed up for you what
was the plan to do once you finish you
know probably come and look in the
financial advisor yeah initially what
they wanted me to be a doctor
what is she doctor he's an engineer I
was engineer so after a year Union
decided that's not for me yeah you know
lectures that is more fun right well
fine it wasn't meaningful as well for me
so yeah properties like every day we're
doing something news you know pushing
you know it's our purpose what's your
biggest tip property tip to people
watching us I would say just bit quieter
difficult question as well I would say
just you know no work network down there
and meet people from money comes from
doesn't it not property yeah if you find
deals money will come and you're gonna
find people if you've got the deals yes
love that man that's all we're doing
probably changed your life is love yeah
absolutely changed our life yes that's
so cool yes that's so cool guys thank
you so much for coming on it's been the
weirdest winners Wednesday ever but it's
been at it and I'm so cheering you on
I'm continuing to watch and achieve on
keep in touch and maybe we'll get you
back for a part to next year who knows
would load yes'm
good job man thank you so much for
watching the video that is the reason
why I'm doing this your success is my
oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success students
you can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course come on on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for
two days to help you get started you can
see what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out